I want to laugh at a Samantha Bee joke I
want to see if I can do that today it's
not shocking the president leapt into
action to save meat because burgers you
in danger girl
so I think there were some jokes in
there I can't be sure and this might be
part of Samantha Bee's genius that she
tells she tells jokes and and nobody
knows that they're jokes so she's
deconstructing comedy that's what I'm
told it's embarrassing that the where's
the beef places out of beef if you like
if someone at Taco Bell was caught
Thinking Inside the bun this is a
professional comedian folks she makes
millions of dollars telling jokes and
yet she's never actually told one so far
as I can tell and so I'm starting to
figure out that when people say Samantha
Bee is funny which I've never actually
heard anyone say that but theoretically
if they do say that they don't mean it
on the scale of comedians right they
they're using a different scale what
they mean is that she's funny for a
feminist